[موسيقى]
احتفل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مع رئيسى
وزراء بريطانيا واستراليا باتفاق اوكوس
على منصه فيغو وتظهر في الخلفيه غواصه من
نوع فرجينيا ستتسلى مثيلاتها استراليا
بنهايه العقد
[موسيقى]
اريد ان اكون واضحا منذ البدايه فلا يكون
هناك اللغط او سوء فهم فهذه النقطه مفصليه
الغواصات تسير بالقوه النوويه وليست مسلحه
نوويا مسيره وليست مسلحه نوويا
جدد الرئيس الامريكي كثيرا على هذه الميزه
في محاوله للتاكيد ان الولايات المتحده لا
تسعى مع استراليا الى الدول في المحيط
اتفاق اوكسو الذي نؤكده هنا في ساندييغو
يمثل اكبر استثمار في امكانيات استراليا
العسكريه في تاريخ بلادنا
ويشمل الاتفاق الذي اعلن عنه بدايه
التعاون بين البحريه الامريكيه
والاستراليه في مجال الغواصات المسيره على
القوات النوويه ثم تسليم استراليا ثلاث
غواصات امريكيه على ان تتعاون بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده في بناء غواصات بصناعه
استراليه
تزيد الغواصات والسفن المسيره بالطاقه
النوويه من مسافه الابحار وهذا يعني
الابتعاد عن شواطئ استراليا والاقتراب من
شواطئ الصين ومن الخطوط البحريه الصينيه
الى الشرق الاوسط من حيث يستوردون الطاقه
في الاشهر الثمانيه عشر الماضيه تصاعدت
التحديات التي واجهناها من اجتياح روسيا
لاوكرانيا الى التصرفات الصينيه
والاضطرابات التي تسببت بها ايران وكوريا
الشماليه وكلها تهدد العالم بالمخاطر
والاضطرابات والانقسام يبدو هذا الاتفاق
على انه تاهيل واضح للقوه العسكريه
الاستراليه بدعما من الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وايا كانت التبريرات فهذا
التاهيل العسكري لاستراليا يبدو موجها ضد
الصين العربيه